NORTH LAWN.
THANK YOU.
>> Sandra: THANK YOU, ED.
THE FDA IS FAST TRACKING
METHODS OF FIGHTING THIS
CORONAVIRUS OUTBREAK.
THE MOST RECENT BEING A TEST
THAT CAN DETECT COVID-19
ANTIBODIES IN JUST TWO MINUTES.
LET’S BRING IN FDA COMMISSIONER
DR. STEVEN HAHN ON THAT.
THANK YOU FOR BEING HERE.
>> THANK YOU, IT’S A PLEASURE
TO BE HERE.
>> Sandra: WE HAVE SO MANY
QUESTIONS FOR YOU.
FIRST I’LL START ON THAT NOTE.
THE TWO-MINUTE CORONAVIRUS TEST.
IS IT EFFECTIVE?
>> SO IF YOU ARE REFERRING TO
THE TEST THAT HAS BEEN SAID TO
BE AVAILABLE FOR ANTIBODY
TESTING, THAT IS CAN YOU DETECT
SOMEONE WHO NOW HAS IMMUNITY
AGAINST IT, WE ARE NOT
AUTHORIZING THOSE TESTS.
WE ARE IN THE PROCESS OF
LOOKING AT APPLICATIONS FOR
THOSE TESTS AND OBVIOUSLY IT’S
A HUGE PRIORITY.
JUST THE POINT IT IS NOT A
DIAGNOSTIC TEST.
IT DOESN’T TELL YOU WHETHER YOU
ACTUALLY HAVE THE DISEASE RIGHT
NOW.
THE TEST THAT’S BEEN ADVERTISED
IS TELL YOU WHETHER YOU’VE BEEN
EXPOSED AND HAS ANTIBODIES.
WE’RE WORKING HARD TO FURTHER
WORK WITH DEVELOPERS OVER THESE
TESTS TO GET AS MANY OF THEM
OUT.
THEY ARE A COMPONENT OF THE
PUBLIC HEALTH EFFORT.
>> Sandra: SOME SAY THE TEST
WOULD BE KEY BECAUSE THEN YOU
HAVE HEALTHY PEOPLE WALKING
AROUND WITH NO SYMPTOMS WHO
MIGHT BE CARRYING THE VIRUS AND
COULD EXPOSE MORE VULNERABLE
PEOPLE LIKE PREGNANT WOMEN OR
THE ELDERLY.
SO DO YOU SEE THAT AS NECESSITY
FOR PRIORITY TO GET IT APPROVED?
>> THERE IS NO QUESTION IT’S A
PRIORITY FOR FDA.
WE ISSUED GUIDANCE SEVERAL
WEEKS AGO AND TEST DEVELOPERS
ARE ALLOWED TO DEVELOP THEM
WITHOUT PRE-MARKET
AUTHORIZATION.
THEY DON’T HAVE TO COME TO US
FIRST.
WE’RE VERY HAPPY TO LOOK AT
THEIR DATA AND INFORMATION.
BUT AGAIN I WANT TO STRESS TO
YOU THIS IS A COMPLIMENTARY
TEST TO THE DIE AGO SIS.
IF YOU HAVE ANTIBODIES TO THE
VIRUS DON’T MEAN YOU ARE
CURRENTLY INFECTED.
IT GOES HAND IN HAND WITH THE
DIAGNOSTIC TEST OF LOOKING AT
WHETHER YOU ACTUALLY HAVE THE
VIRUS PRESENT.
THAT GETS TO YOUR ISSUE OF
WHETHER SOMEONE IS INFECTIOUS.
>> Sandra: OKAY.
SO ON THAT NOTE, WE JUST SAW A
MOMENT AGO THE FDA ANNOUNCED
THE CORONAVIRUS TREATMENT
ACCELERATION PROGRAM.
SO WHERE DO WE STAND AS FAR AS
DISCOVERING TREATMENTS AND
ADVANCING AND IMPROVING THEM
FROM THE FDA?
>> THIS IS GREAT NEWS FOR THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE IN TERMS OF THE
PARTNERSHIP BETWEEN THE PRIVATE
SECTOR AND GOVERNMENT.
FOR THE LAST FOUR TO SIX WEEKS
WE HAVE A GROUP TO LOOK AT THE
ACCELERATION OF THE POTENTIAL
TREATMENTS FOR CORONAVIRUS.
STARTING WITH AGENTS THAT
ACTUALLY SPECIFICALLY TREAT THE
VIRUS AND ALSO SOMETHING CALLED
CONVALESCENT PLASMA.
IT IS A CROSS AGENCY EFFORT
THAT’S A COMPLETE PARTNERSHIP
WITH THE PRIVATE SECTOR AND
STREAMLINING ALL PROCESSES TO
MAKE SURE WE CAN GET THE
APPLICATIONS THAT COME TO US
INTO THE TREATMENT ARENA AND
HOSPITALS AS QUICKLY AS
POSSIBLE.
IT’S REALLY IMPORTANT TO STRESS
THERE ARE NO FDA-APPROVED
THERAPIES FOR COVID-19.
WHAT WE’RE TALKING ABOUT IS
EXPEDITING GETTING POTENTIALLY
POSITIVE THERAPIES THAT COULD
HELP OUT INTO HOSPITALS AND TO
DOCTOR’S HANDS.
TYPICALLY UNDER THE SETTING OF
A CLINICAL TRIAL WHERE WE CAN
GENERATE THE EVIDENCE AND DATA
THAT HELPS FDA TO MAKE
DECISIONS ABOUT THE SAFETY AND
EFFECTIVENESS OF TREATMENTS.
WE’RE PUSHING THAT FORWARD VERY
AGGRESSIVELY.
>> Sandra: I THINK IT’S FAIR TO
SAY YOU SOUND OPTIMISTIC AS FAR
AS PROGRESS ON THAT IS
CONCERNED.
I’LL READ YOU A HEADLINE FROM
THE "WASHINGTON POST" BECAUSE
IN THE MIDDLE OF ALL THIS THERE
IS A LOT OF CRITICISM OF THE
FDA POSSIBLY GOING TOO QUICKLY
WITH SOME OF THESE TREATMENTS
AND POTENTIALLY NOT LOOKING AT
ALL THE RISKS INVOLVED AND
RATHER LOOKING AT JUST TRYING
TO GET FAST HELP.
THE FDA AUTHORIZES WIDESPREAD
USE OF UNPROVEN DRUGS TO TREAT
CORONAVIRUS SAYING POSSIBLE
BENEFIT OUTWEIGHS THE RISK.
THIS PARTICULAR PIECE GOES INTO
THE COMBINATION OF THOSE DRUGS
AND SAYS THAT HEALTH EXPERTS
ARE WARNING THAT THE WELL-KNOWN
SIDE EFFECTS COULD BECOME
COMMON PLACE WITH WIDESPREAD
USE.
IN PARTICULAR LOOKING AT PEOPLE
THAT ALREADY HAVE EXISTING
HEALTH PROBLEMS, HEART
PROBLEMS, TAKING CERTAIN DRUGS,
ANTIDEPRESSANTS AND THAT THESE
COULD BECOME FATAL.
ARE YOU SEEING THE BENEFITS
OUTWEIGH THE POTENTIAL RISKS OF
EXPOSING PEOPLE TO THESE
TREATMENTS?
>> THIS IS A REALLY IMPORTANT
ISSUE AND I WANT TO EXPLAIN IT.
WE ISSUED AN EMERGENCY USE
AUTHORIZATION JUST AS DESCRIBED
IN THAT ARTICLE FOR ENTRY OF
HYDROXYCHLOROQUINE AND
CHLOROQUINE INTO THE SYSTEM.
WE DID NOT APPROVE IT FOR THE
USE OF TREATMENT OF COVID-19.
WHAT IT ALLOWED US TO DO IS
HAVE DONATED DRUG COMING INTO
THE SYSTEM.
THE DRUG WILL BE ALLOCATED FOR
CLINICAL TRIALS WHERE WE’LL BE
ABLE TO ASK THE QUESTION ABOUT
WHETHER THESE DRUGS WORK.
THAT’S THE BEST WAY TO GET THE
DATA AND SCIENCE FOR US TO TELL
AMERICANS WHETHER THIS IS THE
RIGHT DRUG FOR THEM.
IT IS ALSO ALLOWED THE DONATED
DRUG TO COME INTO CIRCULATION
BECAUSE THE OTHER WAY THAT
AMERICANS HAVE THE POTENTIAL TO
GET THIS DRUG IS TO GO TO THEIR
DOCTOR, KNOW ABOUT THE RISKS
AND BENEFITS WITH THEIR DOCTOR,
HAVE A DISCUSSION ABOUT THE
DRUG AND DECIDE WHETHER IT’S
THE RIGHT DRUG FOR THEM TO TAKE.
WE HAVE NOT TAKEN A STANCE NOR
ARE WE ON WHETHER DOCTORS
SHOULD PRESCRIBE IT.
WE’RE PROVIDING FACTS AND
INFORMATION ABOUT THE RISKS AND
BENEFITS.
IT IS AND SHOULD BE A
DOCTOR/PATIENT DECISION.
>> Sandra: WHERE DO WE STAND AS
FAR AS VENTILATORS ARE
CONCERNED?
WE HEAR A LOT OF MIXED MESSAGES
ON THE NEED FOR THOSE
VENTILATORS AND HEARD FROM THE
GOVERNOR OF NEW YORK STATE
TALKING ABOUT NOW THE NEED FOR
SOME HOSPITALS TO PUT TWO
PATIENTS ON ONE VENTILATOR.
WHAT IS THE FDA RECOMMENDING ON
THAT?
ARE WE WHERE WE NEED TO BE AS
FAR AS HAVING THE CAPACITY TO
ADMINISTER THOSE VENTILATORS TO
THE PATIENTS THAT NEED THEM?
>> THE GOOD NEWS HERE IS FEMA
AND HEALTH AND HUMAN SERVICES
ARE WORKING VERY HARD TO
INCREASE CAPACITY.
I’LL TELL YOU WHAT FDA’S ROLE
IS.
IT DOESN’T REGULATE THE
PRACTICE OF MEDICINE.
WE PROVIDE GUIDANCE WHAT’S THE
BEST WAY TO EXPAND THE CAPACITY.
WHAT’S THE BEST WAY TO ACTUALLY
CLEAN THESE VENTILATORS?
WHAT’S THE BEST WAY TO HELP
MANUFACTURERS RAMP UP?
SO THAT WE GET THE BEST DEVICES
IN THE HANDS OF PROVIDERS.
OUR JOB IS TO MAKE SURE THAT
DEVICES, DRUGS, WHATEVER WE’RE
TALKING ABOUT ARE SAFE AND
EFFECTIVE.
WE PROVIDED A LOT OF GUIDANCE
AND FLEXIBILITY AROUND THIS SO
THAT WE CAN EXPAND CAPACITY.
AND THEN WE’RE FEEDING THAT
INFORMATION UP TO HEALTH AND
HUMAN SERVICES AND FEMA AS THEY
LOOK AT THE ALLOCATION AND RAMP
UP IN THE MANUFACTURING.
>> Sandra: WE HEAR THE NEED FOR
THEM AND A LOT OF COMPANIES
HAVE TRIED TO FILL THE VOID.
FORD AND OTHERS HAVE STEPPED IN
TO TRY TO USE THEIR
MANUFACTURING FACILITIES TO
MAKE THOSE VENTILATORS.
APPRECIATE YOUR TIME THIS